[Music]
this next song to Carmelo who was put to
sleep a couple of days ago because he
got too old but apparently he was a very
nice dog and he always let the cat sleep
in the dog bed I'm just a walking my dog
singing my song strolling yeah it's just
me and my dog catching some Sun we can't
go mother feels lonely and blue yeah I
was sad as a sailor I was an angry into
then there was you appeared when I was
entangled with youths and fear and
nerves jangled rankings were moose and
beer we're getting me mangled up a
button I looked in your eyes and I was
no more a failure he looked so wacky and
wild and I said Lord I'm here because
I'm just a walking my dog catching some
Sun we go
yeah it's just me and my dog singing a
song
[Music]
yeah but your hate then your doubt and I
don't care what the politicians about if
you need companion why just go out to
the pound and find yourself a hound and
make that doggie proud cuz that's what
it's all about
- tragic and sad I was the archetypal
loser I was a pageant gone bad then
there was you on time and wagging your
tail and the cutest mind but you was in
jail I said and you I was no longer
alone and I was no more a boozer will
make the happiest home and I said Lord
I'm happy cause I'm just walking my dog
[Music]
it's just the politicians about me
companion watch run to the pound and
find yourself a hound and make that dog
[Music]
that's what it's all
[Applause]
[Music]
you